because that slogan broke men don't
deserve love like pearl was saying
if a slogan or a hashtag was like fat
women don't deserve love it would be a
thing
like it would be like uh they're brought
to be an uproar you can't say that
you're fat shaming
what broke guys don't deserve love yeah
yeah i don't i don't want no scrubs yeah
like
i mean it's all the songs why am i great
until they gotta be like
where does society work
sorry right but we can make an
encouragement song let's encourage girls
to hit the treadmill
it was the workout plan by kanye
yeah
he let you know if you work out you get
sleep and get your surgery you get the
money would you say would you say it's
equal well
would you say that there's equal equally
as many songs for women as there are for
men
of getting on the treadmill yeah
definitely not no definitely not but i
mean you know but i think right so
wouldn't you say that's more of an
exception a perception rather than the
rules we're going by music you look at
you look at um
you hear the songs for women great men
don't deserve um girls right but then
you look at the
male
um male videos or rat videos it's all
skinny
women so
yeah
women so i i mean it's very very i mean
if someone has a fat chick in the video
you're making a statement you're trying
to say something but she's fat
regularly is this going to be a skinny
um beautiful instagram looking
very ambiguous i see i see fat models
all the time but so look at liz but men
aren't looking at yeah
but i'm saying it's catered it's catered
to women like victoria's secret they're
bringing in fat chicks this is supposed
to be the epitome of beauty they're
bringing in fatches that's because
they're realizing that our brands have
understood that the world is universal
not everyone is tall and skinny and they
accept that victoria's secret didn't
that's what now they're trying to jump
on the bandwagon but they're doing it
for their customers
yeah they're catering their kid yeah
they're catering to women
that's what i'm saying like everything's
about women yeah do you think women get
like
more see and to quote another um
comedian bill burr said that women's
issues are taken seriously you know
you've got
ribbons groups
all this kind of stuff like numbers you
can call
um he actually cited a a thing that
happened in america where a wife cut off
her husband's penis
threw it in a garbage disposal right
and he was laughing ah stumpy yeah and
he was saying well if a guy cut off a
woman's teeth and put it in a dryer
would would people be laughing about it
no absolutely not no that's disgusting
yeah well i'm just like what he was
saying like women's stuff is taken more
seriously i think these are over
correction by society in general i think
if you if you take it back
um
before women thought they had um
rights and things like that before that
time maybe it was before the 60s or
something it's what they thought they
didn't have right
yeah sorry
um
then it would have then
as soon as they've they've gained the
the backing from men and things like
that i think what men have done is
they've over corrected in society to the
point where it's tipped so much that now
it's almost like everyone have yeah
it's very clear
because
you know since women after the second
world war when more women joined in the
workforce and the buying power of women
so
yeah you're gonna then slant all your
marketing and everything else
to that buying power you know yeah well
yeah and and it wasn't necessarily
corrected most when you're i think
you're talking about like the right to
vote and that sort of thing but most
people in history didn't have the right
i think it's just more the attitude the
attitude was over corrected so
uh but it's it's over corrected through
things like feminism which is
which is put
um instead where they thought that men
were above women they've suddenly now
put women above men and they haven't
actually made it where they thought they
were going to make it equal they've
actually put i would say that's a
misconception though historically i
don't think they thought men were above
women
yeah yeah that might not be that might
not be accurate that might have not
actually been accurate you know what it
is what i think that that's that's what
is that
one percent of men yeah
well it's that like like feminism is
just women want freedom without
responsibility
like even even with the right to vote
are we equally drafted for combat
situations no that's why we couldn't
vote
i agree
so like that's what feminism constantly
does is it wants more freedom but less
responsibility
and so it's saying like give us the
freedom but not the responsibility that
comes with it
what do you think ladies are you
feminists me personally no
i am a womanist i'm not a feminist
feminist wasn't made created for me it
was created for the white woman so
i don't necessarily one of the dolphins
when i was looking into it didn't say
resonate with me because if i was back
then those times i still don't be able
to vote i still wouldn't be seen as
human so
so what is it what is a womanist then
it's more catered around the black
female experience and the kind of
struggle that we that we go for as black
females and also because in our culture
in general like for example in my
culture i'm ghanaian we have we have we
when we were growing up
but my tribe had ashanti worry warrior
women we had we had people we had women
that were heads of the phone but we
still serve their husbands so it's a
different kind of
um
concept of like oh if your woman's in
power nature
must be submissive or what have you so
that's why i say that i'm i struggle
with that through feminism because of my
culture my background who i am and as i
i
am mortgage for womanism and stuff i'm
still learning about that stuff as well
so yeah
is there a right that you feel like
women don't have in 2022
i mean some rights have been taken away
and it depends what country you go to
um you know obviously in america just
you know stopped
abortion
um before in saudi when women couldn't
women couldn't drive
and you know in some cultures when we
can't get this sorry i'm talking about
i'm talking about the west in the west
oh i mean just because we're in london
so yeah
yeah you know i mean i would say oh
look look by looking in you would say
we've got all the rights we need however
if you even look into because obviously
londoners are very diverse so you go
into the cultures things like that like
you look at um child marriages and um
young young women that are fought into
those things these are still that
already got changed recently to say 18
years she'll be getting married so
there's still some work on the ground to
do in regards to women and their rights
but definitely in the west women are set
are saturated with their rights
would you mean this where they've got
too much rights they've got loads that
loads right i was it too many and it's
got loads of fights i would say it's too
many because you know it's it's the
privilege that we have been in the west
compared to
other countries that have that privilege
so i can't say too many but i could i
could definitely say
if you live in the west as a female in
some in some cultures you will find
you've got a voice where you can you can
talk but then
i think i think we have more rights than
man
but then you know but i also feel like
back to the question of men
a lot of industries are dominated by men
in this country
so why
ah why what do you mean i don't know why
well if you actually think if you had to
think about it
yeah why would you think that those
industries are dominated by men i think
because we live in a patriarchal society
where men are taught i honestly do i
feel like i feel by default okay so then
how how are we in a patriarchy when
there's quotas that are specifically for
women that are encouraged to go in those
fields and not men and there aren't
quotas for men to go in female dominated
fields is this in the